but I was at a Foot Locker looking these
kicks I'm obsessed with their max once
you don't know what the [ __ ] those
aren't doesn't matter so I like those
golden gooses though anyways shout to
the Cutie came in the Weatherspoon Nikes
but I was at the mall and there's this
mom you know that mom was smiling like
straight off the scent of eight-mile
I'll put it that way
and she was yelling at her kid have you
ever wanted to say step in I felt so bad
for the kid man the way she was talking
mean I want the daddy I'm like dude do
something so she's pushing baby and
other kids maybe six and the right bias
and she goes something like Papa went
you like these in the mom maybe just
having a bad day mayor [ __ ] bipolar
just goes off you don't shut the [ __ ] up
you don't shut the [ __ ] up and just
start getting in her face oh my god man
I don't know everything about parenting
time no that ain't the way that's not
and then he got signed she goes you
little [ __ ]
you little [ __ ] [ __ ] I told you we
going store you don't ask for anything
I [ __ ] to are like oh my god I just
stared at him as a cop man you can't you
can't mess with people's kids
yeah probably got you puts a hand on her
I should probably do something yeah I
get secured like what do you do it's
always have that problem when they see a
domestic violence yes that's where they
get hurt cuz you see a guy like a lot of
times they're the stores where the guys
hitting the woman the woman the man the
cop comes in grabs the man the woman
attacks the cop yeah it's like what that
oh you guys have a weird dynamic here
yeah sexual like there's some share
where you guys fight you beater I know
but with King I know a woman with kids
it's different then oh like what's wrong
you know what you're doing here when she
goes up she's gonna [ __ ] eat yep
there's a woman I know there's I used to
work with this woman she told me her
friend she's she's fat she's a big woman
her husband's skinny and and she'll get
her husband to a point where her husband
will put a beating on her and I go
that's terrible and she goes no no no no
she likes it she goes it makes her feel
like a woman
so she'll cry and stuff and then so we
hear her and we used to come in and what
the [ __ ] you know and we hear him
beating her you know I don't know
beating
like you know he'd take his belt off
right away take his about the I love a
wolf yep take his belt off hit her with
a belt hit her and that was hand
fighting and stuff you're right right
she's a big girl and then he's here yeah
now you [ __ ]
any here and then your novel new job
then you'd hear she may be like wait for
it wait for it 10 minutes later five
years later their routine she's downing
that that was their [ __ ] routine that
[ __ ] it that well people are so
complicated and weird relationships
sexuality glue obviously what they were
into Ilyich ops - they said the worst
domestic violence is amongst gays if two
dudes because dude you know there are
yeah [ __ ] and then officer hey bro did
you see Connors post about his little
kid's birthday and it's fat dick and yes
it's not that crazy right post hoc
picture is right I went why is it hogs
together like that he was fat white dick
right there but look at his face - it's
so funny how he does it I feel like he's
doing this now beans do that I think is
a giant fat hog or he just doesn't wear
underwear any pulls to the side
cuz you know what no he was initiated
well there's a bunch of shirt there
appreciate his dick I appreciate him
this kiddos Cuban okay yeah a kid I was
very good-looking fans awesome he's
awesome right yeah I think that for what
that this one - this one's pretty crazy
let me see this on his dick I know he
sold his kid on these things like guys I
think is a fat dick hopefully
congratulations you get this little bit
of fat dick Kratz
cute ass kid yep the kids starting to
look like I'm two kids getting big man
thick kid holy [ __ ] bags that's oh
that's Cox holy [ __ ] pics bro all the
comments are pretty much like Nike
shorts that got it when you have a good
dick day for family photos see the third
pick is hair imma get that do didn't
wear underwear that's that's right he's
not working did you see the
comments on when I posted me blowing up
my jeans sometimes people are [ __ ]
hilarious on Instagram what they say
just about my arse
my wife was horrified because I don't
know why because I'm I get tired of
being aggressive and in charge you ever
have that oh oh I don't really go this
so you like to get [ __ ] on the bottom
I don't like that no I don't so thank
you for filling in the space but I had
people over who I didn't know that well
and maybe an instruction she gave me an
instruction to do something it was like
make sure you're home so that the kids
when they're from 4 to 7 and I was just
tired of solving problems I was tired of
being in charge I was tired of being a
guy man you tired of me man you know
you're tired of being the general of the
count I was tired of being a man and I
and I this is no bull she tried to be in
the head Ewok
yep and all of a sudden I went my little
tail and I began to rub my butt against
it
oh snap me teeth slap my [ __ ] damn bad
feed me a strawberry and stabbing and I
want to poo and I don't know what I was
doing I started hopping in a circle was
she like you're crazy she was like you
are so unattractive I was like I know
punished me for being a lucky bunny no
one wants to feed me a [ __ ]
strawberry I actually have in our video
she was and then I had hunter tail pace
fed me a strawberry mom and I began to
eat it like I was more interested in the
28 year old scientist and I was showing
green blue I was showing her my wheel
kick and and I was with my sister and I
go to her I go she goes where do you
live I live in DC and she goes cool yeah
he should come visit me sometime here
there by the way she was married and
that and she goes what do you do there I
go right now I'm kind of probably gonna
work at a bank and my sister my sister
the grenade we call her the grenade she
goes all right
DC yeah he's in college and my dad pays
everything took my wheels lock off I was
like white but within disorder a wheel
kick she was like wow